la crainte d'un odile plaintes plus que
jamais sur la future relation entre les
deux parties alors que débute le
huitième round des négociations
la tension monte d'un cran entre les
britanniques et l'union européenne
boris johnson se dit prête à claquer la
porte mi octobre faute de compromis
londres appelle bruxelles à plus de
pragmatisme
l'ue doit faire preuve de plus de
réalisme sur notre statut en tant que
pays indépendant
nous ne pouvons plus nous permettre de
ressasser les mêmes choses après six
mois de dialogue
selon des informations du financial
times le gouvernement britannique
pourrait revenir sur des engagements
passés londres envisagerait de présenter
dès ce mercredi un projet de loi visant
à éliminer la portée juridique de
certaines parties de l'accord notamment
en ce qui concerne les réglementations
douanières en irlande du nord
une manoeuvre décrié par bruxelles tout
ce qui a été signé dans le passé doit
être respectée c'est le gage de la
confiance pour l'avenir il n'y aura pas
de compromis pas d'accord avec le
royaume uni au détriment de l'union
européenne et au détriment du marché
unique
l heure actuelle les négociations butent
notamment sur la pêche ou encore les
conditions de concurrence équitables si
aucun accord n'est trouvé
les relations entre l'union européenne
et le royaume uni serait régi par les
règles de l'organisation mondiale du
commerce droits de douane élevés et
contrôles aux frontières plus poussée un
scénario qui pénaliserait davantage
européens et britanniques